[Música]
quando a gente começar fechem os olhos
um pouquinho vamos fazer um exercício de
imaginação
eu quero que vocês imaginem uma
tecnologia superior nova' dora e que
modificou muito o cotidiano de vocês ou
cotidiano da humanidade
agora vocês sabem quem é o criador dessa
tecnologia continua imaginando qualquer
gênero desse evento ouro qualquer um
ingênuo da pessoa que fez isso como ela
se veste como ela age onde ela mora
agora abra os olhos
vocês acham que essa pessoa se parece
comigo
bom não se preocupem é geralmente as
imagens que vem na nossa cabeça do que
um tecnologia está um empreendedor um
inventor um cientista aquelas imagens
que a vida inteira foram mostrados pra
gente do que esse tipo de pessoas e
parece claro eram as mesmas que
apareciam sempre quando você procurava
no google por esses termos
então isso mostra muito pra gente que
existe uma imagem específica do que a
gente imagina que são essas pessoas
pra mim era esse aqui quando eu era
pequena eu assistia muito laboratório de
dexter e eu achava o máximo eu também
queria ser uma cientista tem um
laboratório secreto no laboratório de
dexter tenha de pedir a irmã dela e ela
está ali pra destruir tudo que ele faz
só que quando eu pensava com quem eu me
identificava eu acabei me identificando
mais conde de hadid elas usavam vestidos
e usava vestidos ela dançava balé e eu
adorava dançar ela conversava bastante
com as amigas dela eu gostava muito de
conversar inclusive faço isso até hoje
então eu quando olhava para os exemplos
que eu tinha na ficção nos desenhos
quando olhava a história eu não achava
ninguém que se parece comigo mas não se
preocupem essa história conta hoje pra
vocês não é uma história de
arrependimento
hoje né
o trabalho na intersecção de tecnologia
cultura comunicação e ao longo desse
tempo trabalhando com essas coisas
pesquisando e desenvolvendo projetos
a gente vai entendendo que algumas
barreiras que a gente acreditava que
elas eram bem fixas na verdade elas são
um pouco mais habitadas do que a gente
imagina
e é isso um pouco da minha jornada
hoje eu trabalho bastante com um
tentando democratizar esse acesso das
pessoas à tecnologia e no meu campo de
estudos tecnologia não é simplesmente
artefatos ou ferramentas é tudo aquilo
que o ser humano cria para resolver
algum problema
então se a gente pensar nessa definição
linguagem por exemplo também entra como
a tecnologia e à tecnologia ao mesmo
tempo nós construímos ela e aí ela
começa a construir a gente de volta e
quando a gente pensa que se a tecnologia
é criada pelos seres humanos
elas acabam por dar os valores a visão
de mundo aquilo que aquele criador tem
afinal foi um humano que o fez
vamos pensar agora no outro exercício eu
quero que vocês imaginem não fechar os
olhos dessa vez uma tecnologia que ela
atendeu esses três critérios
uma tecnologia que ela economizou
bastante o tempo das pessoas ou de vocês
que ela diminuiu distâncias percorridas
e que ela economizou bastante energia
pensaram geralmente quando eu faço
exercício já fez isso com bastante gente
assim eo pessoal respondia é o celular é
o carro ao gps ou smartphone
isso faz muito sentido quando a gente
pensa na nossa vivência na nossa
história aquilo que faz sentido pra
nossa vida o nosso cotidiano
só que eu conversava com a minha avó
saiba que ela me contava ela me contava
que a tecnologia que fez tudo isso pra
ela era a máquina de lavar
ela contava pra mim que ela gasta muita
energia o avanço roupa ela tinha às
vezes e olha que já tinha água encanada
nem acabava a água tinha que comprar a
água
ela tinha gastava muito tempo né
separando as roupas fazendo as roupas
enfim pra hoje pra gente pensando que a
gente ainda tem ali um pelo ibge é uma
uma média de uns 30% dos brasileiros que
não têm eletrodomésticos ou por exemplo
a promessa da lavadora né
ou por exemplo um quinto da população
brasileira que agora está cozinhando com
carvão ou lenha
essa tecnologia pode ser uma tecnologia
que tem um impacto muito profundo
nesse cotidiano dessas pessoas às vezes
muito maior do que esse smartphone o gps
porque aquelas pessoas que desenvolvem
essa atividade é esse tipo de tecnologia
faz muito sentido
eu fiz exercícios com vocês pra mostrar
que aquilo que a gente vivencia aquilo
que a gente viver aquilo que foi
ensinado pra gente muitas vezes também
limita a nossa imaginação ou aquilo que
a gente entende cooper o que é
tecnologia neowin quem pode fazer
tecnologia
essa é a nossa condição histórica se a
gente pensar né até interessante que até
pouquíssima gerações atrás uma mulher
está falando num espaço público era uma
coisa que seria impensável
ainda bem que a gente viu que as coisas
mudaram nem as coisas elas não eram elas
estavam a história da humanidade mostra
muito isso pra gente
esse é um exemplo clássico das ciências
sociais é um estudo muito clássico que
chama desenhe um cientista você dá papel
e caneta para as crianças e você pede
que elas desenham um cientista e os
resultados apesar de parecerem não muito
surpreendentes um pouco desanimadores é
do a noroeste ela pegou os mais de cinco
mil desenhos do desenho cientista que
crianças fizeram e e quando foi ver o
resultado e perceberam que apenas 28
desses cinco mil desenhos eram
cientistas mulheres e nenhum dos meninos
desenhou uma sente essa mulher sabe aí a
gente já sabe né isso tem a gente tem
uma história que fez acontecer teve um
monte de fatores né
e a gente está vendo as tendências e tá
melhorando nas crianças está desenhando
agora mais mulheres cientistas e olha eu
super positiva eu vejo que as coisas
estão realmente melhorando a gente tem
né a gente está ganhando espaço vários
grupos diferentes que não tinha espaço
tão ganhando só que ainda assim a gente
tem essas limitações de imaginação a
gente ainda tem muitas barreiras para
ser quebradas principalmente nessas
construções é isso que a gente tem que
se preocupar bastante as tecnologias por
elas serem essas cristalizações dos seus
criadores né
elas herdarem esses valores elas como o
cruzeiro explica elas não são boas nem
ruim mas muito menos neutras
o que acontece por exemplo quando a
gente tem um grupo muito específico de
pessoas criando tecnologia em escala
global
a gente acha mesmo que um menino do vale
do silício ele vai entender quais são as
felicidades os sonhos as dificuldades de
uma mulher da periferia do brasil porque
é isso que está acontecendo hoje em dia
nós temos essas técnicas litis grupos
muito pequenos de pessoas que estão
construindo tecnologia pra todo mundo né
a gente tem ali é sempre os mesmos
companhias fazendo essas coisas num
local e que alcança essa escala global
quando a gente pensa na minha pesquisa
hoje o meu foco é principalmente
inteligência artificial por causa dos
investimentos que estão acontecendo
nessa tecnologia e também por causa dos
do foco não é que tá acontecendo quando
fui olhar minha pesquisa nisso a gente
percebeu que tem alguns problemas
acontecendo dentro dessa tecnologia como
inteligência artificial ela se propõe a
procurar padrões ea gente tem muitos
dados hoje em dia a gente precisa achar
esses padrões não é pra gente fazer um
pouco de sentido no mundo que a gente
vive alguns problemas aconteceram como
por exemplo algum ou um reconhecimento é
do google de imagens acabou
classificando pessoas negras como
gorilas
a gente sabe hoje que o reconhecimento
facial né
quanto mais escura a pele da pessoa - a
eficácia menor eficácia de conhecer
aquela pele nossa mas como é que isso
acontece é como é que empresas como
apple google hp enfim elas fazem com que
essas tecnologias têm
esse problema bons inteligência
artificial
ela depende dessas bases de dados ea
maior parte das bases de dados
elas são feitas não é com elas se
baseiam em fotos de pessoas brancas ou
então os desenvolvedores que estão ali
só tem uma cor de pele específica a
inteligência acaba entendendo que áquila
humano e outras coisas que não foi
ensinada para ela que é humano não é e
ela acaba se confundindo a gente tem por
exemplo a amazon que fez recentemente
uma ferramenta para o recrutamento para
ajudar né os recrutadores ele achar qual
é o melhor currículo e aí o que
aconteceu ele colocava numa escala de
preferência o gol o time entendeu o que
nos cargos de diretores dos cargos mais
técnicos em sua maioria a sua maioria
eram homens
então se aquele currículo ele tinha
alguma menção que aquela pessoa uma
mulher
a escala de preferência um pouco para
baixo
quanto mais a gente utilizar essas
tecnologias principalmente essas que se
baseia nessas técnicas por exemplo the
machine learning a gente pode ver esse
tipo de coisa acontecendo cada vez mais
por isso que é interessante nos
preocuparmos e temos muita atenção com
esse tipo de tecnologia
essas tecnologias nela se baseia em duas
vezes nesse espírito esses estereótipos
essa procura de padrões
o google por exemplo quando ele mostrava
né coisas específicas pessoas mais
específicas um mesmo padrão de pessoas
quando você procurava por exemplo por
cientista né
ele estava simplesmente mostrando que
ele aprendeu elkis pela história o que
eram os cientistas então se a gente hoje
tem tanta gente diferente no mundo né
a gente precisa recomeçar a pensar como
é que a gente consegue fazer essas
tecnologias para serem mais diversas
para abarcar todas as pessoas essas
novas necessidades desses grupos que a
gente sabe que fizeram parte
então eu acho que a solução não é
simplesmente a um novo hardware ou um
novo software
a gente precisa daquilo que vem antes de
tudo isso a gente precisa de mentes de
cérebro de imaginação
a gente já entendeu né quando a gente vê
todos esses problemas que mostrei pra
vocês pessoas foram lá conseguiram
entender viram que isso estava
acontecendo
só que isso só aconteceu quando pessoas
diferentes daqueles grupos entraram em
contato com essas tecnologias
então como na natureza a gente já
entende que uma das respostas para esse
novas idéias para esses novos mundos pra
gente conseguir criar esses novos
futuros é a diversidade
a gente sabe é que quando quanto mais
diverso mais propenso a mutação nós
podemos cinema a gente está pronto para
esse passo o próximo passo evolutivo
quando a gente tem essa maior
diversidade
então na minha pesquisa eu vi que pra
gente pode trabalhar né esse tipo de
questão trabalhando bastante o passado o
presente eo futuro
no passado nós precisamos retomar as
histórias daqueles que foram apagados
não é que tiveram contribuições mas eles
foram se também sistematicamente apagado
da nossa história então a gente precisa
retomar aqueles que fizeram esse tipo de
coisa
recentemente por exemplo a gente teve
aquele filme das mulheres negras não é
que ajudar o homem a chegar à lua o
filme de hollywood esse tipo de coisa
trazer essas pessoas que elas não eram
contadas histórias pra que elas outras
pessoas possam também se identificar se
inspirar e fazer aquilo acontecer lá em
são paulo a gente tem dois grupos maria
lábio preta lab que o que elas fizeram
fizeram uma rápida tona
basicamente elas iam pesquisavam a
história dessas mulheres que não tinham
uma página na wikipédia e a gente sabe é
que hoje em dia se você não tem uma
página no wikipédia você praticamente
não existe e colocavam mulheres
cientistas inventor as criadoras
então é só uma maneira de a gente
trabalhar esse passado no presente a
gente precisa mais de políticas
afirmativas e mostrar que as pessoas que
elas estão aqui agora elas podem
participar desses processos que elas
podem também falar de tecnologia podem
participar dessa construção em 2017 é
quase zero 42 que essa iniciativa pra
juntar pessoas e tecnologias de crianças
base um pouco mais democráticas
a gente fez uma série de workshops na
periferia de são paulo e era um workshop
de três horas ea gente falava bastante
the block em inteligência artificial
cripto moedas e as pessoas que
participavam desse workshop às vezes
elas não tinham a cor a idade a condição
elas não viviam daquela maneira que a
gente imagina
normalmente que um cientista o
tecnologia estão empreendedor é como
aquelas imagens que nós temos as pessoas
só que ali eu vi aquelas poucas horas e
quando a gente criar uma ponte ea gente
mostrar pra cima eu aprendia tanto com
elas me ensinavam e tinham em sites tão
incríveis assim eu vi por exemplo
velhinhas elas pensando nesse sistema
super sofisticado de inteligência
artificial para ajudar
elas nos maus tratos que elas recebiam
as vezes do posto de saúde eu vi meninas
da periferia fazendo questionamentos
muito parecidos sobre inteligência
artificial que estão rolando no
instituto de tecnologia de massachusetts
não emite e quando a gente fala do
futuro eu acho que um dos maiores
perigos são as narrativas únicas porque
quando a gente tem uma narrativa única
que ela narrativa está todo mundo
contando como o futuro vai ser e por um
grupo muito grande a gente acaba tendo a
acreditar que é o futuro vai ser daquele
jeito
então eu não sei vocês mas eu realmente
não acho que o futuro da humanidade vai
ser o colapso ambiental ea gente vai ter
que entrar num foguete e embora pra
marte
eu acho que tem vários outros que a
gente pode pensar a gente tem a
capacidade de pensar ea gente pode criar
quando penso nesse tipo de futuro por
exemplo exterminador do futuro que vai
destruir tudo raul 9 mil fica tipo mi
esse tipo de destoca piá não me assusta
em nada porque a distopia que me assusta
de verdade é todo dia que a gente está
vendo agora que eu tenho um grupo muito
pequeno de pessoas construindo essa
tecnologia pra todo mundo construindo
tecnologias são às vezes baseadas em
prender nossa atenção ganhar mais likes
tecnologias que não estão preocupadas em
igualdade social justiça
isso é uma na hora e paridade econômica
esse tipo de coisa que me assusta ea
gente está vivendo agora
essas estruturas eles não me assustam
quando eu vejo as soluções e os futuros
que a gente já tá criando né eu vejo que
por exemplo no brasil nós temos muita
imaginação muita capacidade criativa
para fazer esses novos futuros nos
workshops por exemplo que o conduzia eu
vi pessoas pensando em formas diferentes
de pensar hierarquia dentro das suas
organizações cidades que elas tinham
menos resíduos
a gente tem toda essa capacidade
imaginativa aqui hoje a gente tem quase
netão alcançando aí os 8 bilhões de
pessoas no mundo então pensa que é cada
pessoa ocupando um espaço específico é
físico do planeta olhando então o mundo
com uma perspectiva diferente
só que às vezes a gente está preso
nesse mesmo espaço imaginativo a gente
está vendo as mesmas coisas pensando as
mesmas soluções repetindo de novo e de
novo
quanto às tecnologias a gente ainda vai
criar que vão acabar marginalizando os
grupos que vão ter um ponto cego em
relação a algumas pessoas
a dona harry que é uma antropologia que
escreveu manifeste borg
ela conta isso pra gente que importa
quais histórias contam histórias importa
quais pensamentos pensão pensamentos
importa quais mundos habitam mundos
então pra gente conseguir criar esses
novos mundos a gente tem que começar a
imaginar essas novas histórias
pensando esses novos pensamentos e junto
com isso nessa diversidade grande
então eu vejo que cada pessoa ela tem um
papel nessa rede
alguns deles vão criar soluções outros
vão criar legislações outros vão criar
pesquisas
eu acho que na verdade todo mundo tem
que descobrir com esse papel na sua rede
eu acredito que aqui todo mundo é um
criador só basta saber do que é obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]